consultations publiques sur sa
reconstruction.
Kim Vermette.
- C'est un carrefour névralgique
de l'Ouest de Montréal. Chaque
jour, près de 80 000 voitures
et camions circulent dans
le secteur de l'échangeur
Saint-Pierre. Construit dans
les années 60, il a fait l'objet
de nombreux travaux de réfection
au fil des années. Il devra Il a
maintenant être reconstruit.
MAYA VODANOVIC, mairesse de
l'arrondissement de Lachine
- Il ne convient pas
niaux camionneurs,
ni aux automobilistes,
ni aux piétons,
ni aux cyclistes.
- Cet axe routier
entre Dorval et l'échangeur
Turcot. Il a toujours été très
fréquenté. Et pour les piétons
et les cyclistes qui transitent
changeur, il y a un
important enjeu de sécurité.
- C'est trop compliqué parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de voitures
et c'est dangereux pour
les vélos.
- Mais ici, il faut faire
vraiment attention. Moins
de 50 % du monde n'indique
pas avec leur signal.
- Entre 2011 et 2015,
4670 collisions sont survenues
sous l'échangeur. Il y a eu
sept morts. Parmi ces accidents,
400 ont impliqué des cyclist
et des piétons. La mairesse
de l'arrondissement réclame des
changements depuis des années.
- Ça fait déjà huit ansqu'on ens
aux citoyens : ça s'en vient,
ça s'en vient. Mais là, au moins
je pense que le mi que le mi que
des Transports nous écoute.
- Une consultation publique
se tientLe ministère
des Transports analyse
différents concepts et veut
entendre les préoccupations
de la population. Mais
les diffles diffles diffles difs
de pression et les spécialistes
concernés ont une demande
claire : que l'échangeur
soit rebâti différement.
CATHERINE HOUBART,
directrice du GRAME
- C'est un gros défi. Il va
falloir concilier le transport
routier, qui est important
dans ce secteur-là, mais avec
les enjeux tout aussi importants
de déplacement des populations
locales.
- Le ministère des Trans
du Québec considère que
l'échangeur Saint-Pierre est
arrivé à la fin de sa vie utile,
sa reconstruction. De plus,
l'échéancier des travaux
n'est pas connu pour le moment.
Ici Kim Vermett
Radio-Canada, Mon